binder vor moment ich komme dann
versuche ich noch einmal nein das geht
nicht
hallo und herzlich willkommen leute und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu homo play
mit martin hey da bist du okay gut wir
mit den flinken stil finden aber ich
weiß nicht genau wo die ideale sehr blöd
jetzt ist das thorrer ist okay wenn ich
darunter gucke sehe ich das dann noch
ist mein gott du bist so schlecht
ich konnte ja nicht durch gucken also
ich habe es gefunden
okay ich hab es auch voll cool mit dem
mario hier ist nach bänden okay du hast
was zu essen
jetzt hier live na ja jetzt gerade bei
mir in minecraft hast was zu essen
aber das muss ja ich weiß es war das gar
nicht gesehen
walter hatte steht nicht stimmt nicht
martin held du hast auch im bett
geschlafen
ja aber das irgendwie weg moment noch
mal
dass wir nochmal bett schlafen ich sage
nochmal oder warte aber jetzt machst du
wieder nicht sterben weil er ich weiß
schwer doch ob das mit dem kann ich
nicht
ach du sch wir müssen ehrlich die betten
woanders hinstellen wenn ich da vorne
nicht mit einem raum bin ich doch so
hell wie haste kratzer auf abgewinnen
ich cool dass ich habe einfach nur ein
bisschen spielchen gemacht wird steht
jetzt macht er so katholisch ich die
ganze zeit klicken ich habe richtig
angst nein ich werde die fledermaus
töten
dass wir junge ich selber deiner darauf
ich hätte damals schlägt zurück
ich verfolge mal mit opti fein so den
sport kann man nicht schaffen der und
witzig nicht schaffen das aber viel zu
lange
philippe lakos enten das dazwischen vier
dazwischen hey du bist jetzt sage sport
jetzt geht es ja so revanche 98 am tag
level lasse ihr werdet ihr werdet ihr
auf einmal zwei blöcke diesmal nicht ich
dachte ich an zeit noch einen blog so
locker weg ja deswegen auch habe ich
gerade vier blöcke gesagt so guckt der
sprung in das unternehmen dennoch nicht
der hier denke dabei nicht das geht
einfach nicht nein
vielleicht musste eine der dabei so
schubsen wie soll man dann wenn man
single player spielt ja scheiße gut ich
das schon wieder unsichtbar
nein es geht einfach nicht es geht nicht
es geht
es geht nicht wie soll das denn gehen
jetzt dass die fledermaus in ruhe ich
kann ihn nicht treffen
scheiße vielleicht kaufe die einfach
nicht töten weil sie viel zu schnell für
dich ist ja ich glaube es auch ja ich
glaub ich bin nicht so langsam
ich bin tot
fast geschafft fast geschafft fast
geschafft man ja fast geschafft ist aber
nicht ganz geschafft du die fledermaus
ist gestorben
die lava chf liegt ich sesshaft ja ich
dachte die mobs wendt klüger scheiße
warten wir springen jetzt mal bis zum
ende dann gebe ich dir so ein schubser
ich probiert noch einmal ich warte dann
da so lange da ist doch ich bin ich hab
so weit anlauf genommen
ich wollte trotzdem homo ich hab's
geschafft
mein gott schon wieder zurückgelaufen
ich dachte so viel anlauf nehmen sonst
schauen wir einmal alles naja ich heiße
ich hätte fast überholt
ein bisschen boden drin
ruffalo war vorhin auch welche volkwein
bedienen du bist am boden drin
ich habe immer noch eine fledermaus
alter schon wieder anlaufen halter
schiff gedrückt
geschafft nein nicht man erhält jetzt
kommt jetzt ich hab das jetzt ja wie
viele fledermäuse da jetzt sind bei mir
bist unsichtbar arbeit freund viele
fledermäuse ach du bist gestorben ich
dachte du wärst unsichtbar versuch mit
schlagen bevor er moment ich komme
weiter versuche ich noch einmal nein das
geht nicht
das war der schwierigste job von allen
weil der nach zum teil auch leitern also
die sind nicht so schwierig die damals
schlaf stift leitern hoch zu laufen
aion deinen scheiß laptop hab's
geschafft hat es geschafft als wenn doch
kommt doch alles komplett geschafft gut
maggie thatcher sieht muss einfach in
einem durch springen partie sind betten
kommt mir moment
warte so gdp gott ich vergesse dieses
scheiß tpk consulter nach oben drücken
nein nachher der geleisteten der pause
wir haben ist es nämlich dort heute der
gleiche tag wie die anderen folgen wo
wieder aufgenommen haben weil ich war
einfach nur kurz bisschen damit kurzen
pause macht martin kessler baby doc aber
schnell weg von dem ich noch weiter
steigt dass er nicht so schnell wie ich
irgendwas dorf auf dem schild sie ja
doch auf was sind das möchte
ein gesteht die rechte schlaghand leben
verloren weil ich da geht runter
gefallen wenn auch nicht so nein bis
jetzt
der transport protection da hab ich
nicht ganz seriös spielen professionell
hinunter gefallen wo wir sind ja scheiße
ich verfolge ich war nicht mehr da oben
ich bin ja da war ich auch gerade da
auch hier auch hier auch und hier oben
auch schon geschafft
arschloch ich heiße sie lang
klassenleiter hab's geschafft navy cis
ist hat er zu mit einem o geschrieben
wird als man muss auf schalter drücken
damit das hier funktioniert ich mache
kein bock lappen
du musst auf den schalter drücken denn
schon darüber ich drücke die ganze zeit
drauf gewartet
moment moment
ja alter immer wieder gar nicht trickst
bin ich drauf sodass man extra obendrauf
ok wenn schon wieder ein weiter nein
alter dass es viel zu krank israel
juni aber danach haben was glaube ich
also dass es dann file station 2 von 2
und danach ist dann nur noch die nok was
sind jetzt voll viel und nicht ein
trackpoint ach du scheiße solch weil die
betten holen
die so als ob wir sterben wobei sollten
wir hier sterben martina falls
herunterfällt und entfernen da kann man
nicht stemmen er wies sofort da oben
nein
hey das ja nee ich noch nicht so oft
eigentlich hey du ich hab meine
handynummer verloren kann ich dahin
haben am besten als ich an geschrieben
hast du hast dein handy verloren also
jannis freund von uns der ist nicht
gerade klug
nein also es gibt da einen typen der
heißt jan und ich hab den halt
zugeschrieben so verstellt ich habe den
ball whatsapp geschrieben was man
eigentlich einmal mit dem handy macht
und da habe ich inhalt geschrieben
wir haben ich habe mein handy verloren
weiß wie das ist und er schreibt nichts
zu erkennen vielleicht bei der
fahrschule weil ich war vorher bei der
fahrschule nicht so ok dann könnte es
erst nicht gerafft und martina alter ja
nur bis so blöd
dann hat jetzt verstanden man es einfach
nur eine klasse für sich sagen war ja
das ist nett ausgedrückt letztes jahr in
mathe sagt ein lehrer jan hier 50
prozent der schüler kein mathe 18 55 70
prozent der schüler können machte wenn
dann sagt jahns soll ja dann bald zu den
anderen 18
der scb hat hat er extra gesagt dass
sein spruch den gab es macht also für
mich gestorben
ja guck mal ein spruch den gab's noch
nie hätte ich mal die bett nicht geholt
ich drücke mal drauf ich drücke auf ok
drück
ich hab's geschafft ja es wirklich immer
drauf so ha ha das schaffen wir nicht
das ist mal gleich machen das uns selber
checkpoint setzen
ok also selber in die leiter nehmen oder
so game mode 1 2 munz leiter so 64
gaylord 0.60 leitern ich habe es vorhin
schon bis da geschafft sv bis hier
das heißt wir setzen uns jetzt weiter
dran ja mach du zuerst ladies first sage
ich immer so gerne ich bin gleich tot
ich hab's geschafft das heißt jetzt nur
der nächste jackpot gehen runter runter
dann kannst du dann scheckbuch machen ok
ich dass man leicht dass martin reicht
das ich glaub nachschlag nicht das war
knapp
martin wir haben nicht so viele
sicher ist sicher nein ich jetzt was
geschafft so ein komischer back ich doch
gleich aus auf dem blog drauf
mai in euch steckt im blog fest ammann
ich lass mir mein leben generieren und
guckt ihr bis hin zu fast geschafft habe
deshalb dass er knapp rechts kacke
verdammt noch mal
so
bis zum schlechten leitern hier blau
während auf der leiters kann man denn
eigentlich weh tun
doch kann man eigentlich meine ich wenn
du jetzt am klettern bist ja geschafft
hahahahaha ich hoffe dass jetzt auch
markiert checkpoint wenn darunter fällt
und wer sagt ich bin schlecht du sollst
nicht so laut reden weil du bist jetzt
wieder runter gefallen